the thing that keeps people from
becoming wealthy is a they don't apply
themselves to a simple set of principles
and B by not applying themselves to that
simple set of principles they fall for
these get rich quick crap and they they
have these tremendous setbacks yeah you
know I went and bought 10 houses and put
them on Airbnb only to find out the and
leverage all of them to their eyeballs
only to find out that Airbnb is now
illegal in two of those cities and only
to find out that Airbnb in the rest of
the cities is completely flooded and I
can't keep them full and so I'm not
making any money and the guy on Tick
Tock lied to me yeah because he didn't
know what the flip he's talking about